you make a case and this is one reason
why I like both your work and your book
is that you didn't do what some people
do is like hey this stuff's going on and
uh and um you know let's hope for the
best
instead you actually make the case and
say okay here's what you need number one
you need a new narrative uh number two
you need a coalition of countervailing
interests and then number three you need
some policies you're going for
um so let's start with number one what
is the conventional narrative and then
what do you think the new narrative
should be or has to be thank you Andrew
I think that's really to me 50 of the
fight is that new narrative and that
means first of all we agree on
what are feasible and desirable
aspirations
and there I think to me
that's quite obvious we want Ai and
other new technologies but especially AI
to go in a pro-human Direction
be a tool in the hands of humans
from all backgrounds make them more
productive more informed better citizens
better workers
not disempowered them Empower them I
think we have to agree on this again not
everybody would agree with that some
people may agree
on the outside but in the inside they
say no wouldn't it be better if we could
just eliminate these workers and some
people who say that's not feasible then
we get into some technical discussions
that's why you know in the book we go
back to the sort of competing visions of
what machines and what digital
Technologies are about are they going to
be
inevitable
autonomous machine intelligent type of
objects or could they be tools for
humans machines that are useful to
humans I think those two visions are
going to be Central to it and then once
we agree on this aspiration I think the
narrative is about whether if there is
something good technology will naturally
go to it sort of the technoptimist view
or whether we can entrust it to some
techno Geniuses be it some Outlet today
or whether it was Bill Gates in the past
so sort of great people obviously very
creative but can we and trust them
because they're going to follow their
own Vision they're going to follow their
own interests and if we just entrust
them you know if we trust them too much
if we Empower them too much then
alternative voices are going to be
drowned so the narrative is about what
we want and how Society can have a voice
in it via the competitive process new
firms entering but also through sort of
the deliberation the Democratic process
the media Civil Society organizations
podcasts people sort of expressing their
concerns their views their alternative
paths towards it you talk about look
that there's a handful of technologists
that kind of dominate the discourse uh
and they naturally will not be making
this more human-centered case so let's
say that you have a human-centered case
and you say we should be at the center
of the set of innovation and we
shouldn't expect this just to magically
happen which by the way I see all the
time
out there I'm sure you do too it's like
oh don't worry you know magical stuff
invisible hand I was like look the the
invisible hands is gonna
scrub out a lot of people
I thought this one the Invisible Hand
and if you question it you're a lotite
yes yeah no I mean hey take it from the
MIT economics professor that you know
you might need you might need to do a
little more uh so then then you have
this uh Coalition of interests who come
together and I guess you cited many of
them just now
um uh where you you talk about various
interest groups um which at this point
should be the most of us since I think
most of us realize that we're somewhat
subject to this
um and then clear policy goals uh and
you make cases for some pretty big
policy Investments uh including
strengthening the the social safety net
in the US absolutely absolutely look I
think
The Narrative has to change
you need this to be embedded in an
Institutional grounding countervailing
Powers you know better working democracy
but at the end of the day technology is
not going to take care of itself unless
you want to just follow the same path so
you need some sort of inducements for
different types of new technologies to
emerge and the current equilibrium to be
modified so for that we need policies we
need the right policies nobody knows
what these policies are
and there's a very good reason for that
because we haven't been experimenting
with them
everybody says our way you know I accept
now that we need some AI regulation but
we don't know what AI regulation should
look like because we have completely
abrogated our responsibility to regulate
digital Technologies for at least the
last one two two decades probably more
so those policies have to be viewed as
ideas that need to be explored more
but they gained it objectives are very
clear this country has reached a level
of inequality and poverty that's really
unacceptable in the 21st century with
such
great abundance that exists around us so
we have to strengthen the social safety
net absolutely
but there I also think
it's not just a social safety net
because I don't think a society in which
earned income is very very unequal
and then we just
create a somewhat more equal
distribution by taxes and transfers
would be a happy one it would create a
huge status inequality it would be
always subject to inequality again
exploding even more and the political
equilibrium being captured by the people
who have the income and quite honestly I
actually think we can do better because
if we can use AI in a more pro-human
pro-worker Direction I think we can
create the kinds of good jobs that were
the
you know Mainstay of the middle class
existence that the United States was so
good at for most of the 20 uh most of
the the post-war era
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guests thank you